- Everything American is
generally bigger than what we have
and therefore probably better?
(upbeat piano music)
- Laffy taffy
- Laffy taffy!
It's like a Yorkshire thing, laffy taffy
- Laffy taffy.
- This is a two-flavor mystery swirl.
- Oh it's very sticky to
the wrapping, look at that.
- Oh God, this is really,
how d'you eat this?
- Opening that and attempting to
disentangle it from the
wrapping is traumatic.
- This is a perfect thing
to give a four year old
just before they go to bed.
- (laughs)
- It's filler, it's like wall filler
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah!
- I could have a couple of these.
- Yeah I could eat like five of these
and then go do some crimes.
- No preservatives, and always fat free.
- They actually taste quite nice.
- Trying to untwist it, and it's
- That'll take you awhile.
- What if you use it as a straw.
- Did that work?
- Their taste is like an
aftertaste, isn't it, it's like...
- I feel like they're quite nothingness
- There is no flavor
(blowing through redvines, laughing)
- Is this a halloween sweet?
There was an episode of
Sabrina the Teenage Witch
in which they had unlimited candy corn.
- I saw the packet and
I was like Jelly Belly?
- No
- And it's not.
- I'm doing two
- Yeah, same.
- it kinda tastes like play-doh
- I always thought they were a lot softer
when I saw them on TV, like
I thought they were kind of like squidgy
- Yeah, sort of marshmallowy.
- D'you think the different
colors have different flavors?
- Um, yellow
- Banana?
A little bit of banana?
- Orange, no...
- Okay
- No.
- It just tastes of despair.
- I never understand spray being a thing.
- This sweet just doesn't give a f*ck.
- (laughs and mumbles)
- You get a really sour taste,
you get a weird freshness
from the watermelon.
- Consuming large quantities
within a brief period
may cause temporary irritation
to sensitive tongues.
- (laughs)
- Three, two, one, go.
(laughs)
- That was a bad idea!
- Do you taste anything?
(laughs)
- Six blasts of that and you'll be,
you know, bouncing off the walls.
- Do the police carry that?
- (laughs)
- Brilliant, well done
America, that was incredible
I'm gonna put some up my nose.
- And snort it?
- Okay, here we go.
- It says don't put it
in a sensitive place.
- Wow.